magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman i've been
getting more and more emails from from
you guys from people in the audience
where
folks are increasingly confused about
is russia making progress is russia
going to be taking over ukraine
or is russia losing because anecdotally
we have for example what we're going to
start with today the story of russia
seizing the first major ukrainian city
which would suggest well yeah it does
seem as though russia is ultimately
going to take ukraine but at the same
time there are widespread reports of
russian soldiers breaking down crying
surrendering in ukraine calling mommy
quite literally i mean soldiers just
calling their moms uh and how could both
be true and the the way that both can be
true
is that on the one hand
russia's military is so dramatically
larger and more powerful than that of
ukraine that there's some feeling of
almost inevitability as to the ability
of russia to make progress into ukraine
but at the same time individually there
are
soldiers
groups of soldiers that don't want to be
there that don't want to do what they've
been sent to do
and are just bailing and both can be
true because the conflict is becoming so
widespread and more than one thing can
happen at the same time so bear that in
mind as we talk about this first
headline the bbc reporting russian
troops have taken control of the key
city of kersun
and this is considered the first quote
major city taken control of by russia
close to 300 000 people so not a massive
metropolis but certainly not a small
town
bbc reporting russian forces have seized
control
of a key port city in southern ukraine
kerason is the first major city taken by
russia after heavy fighting now one week
into the invasion it's mayor igor
kolikav
said russian troops forced their way
into the city council building and have
now imposed a curfew on residents so
the the city appears to truly have been
taken in the literal sense of the word
several cities are under intense
shelling wednesday was one of the most
destructive days of the fighting an
investigation into possible war crimes
and crimes against humanity has been
launched in the icc we talked about that
request earlier this week russia has for
the first time admitted taking heavy
military casualties
498 troops killed 1600 injured now this
this number is not a small detail
um for
a force as overwhelming as that of of
russia's is relative to ukraine's the
fact that in a week
500 they're admitting 500 have died and
remember what they admit and the full
scope of it may be two different things
they're admitting to almost 100 dead a
day now does putin care about that no
probably not but that is not an
insignificant number based on the
military analyses that i've seen now one
other thing i want to point to here that
is uh important
in a facebook post mr kolikov who's the
mayor of curson said russian forces were
in control of the city
he urged russian soldiers not to shoot
at civilians saying there are no
ukrainian forces in the city and
increasingly and as i've said to you
guys before
we are tr when things are moving so
quickly it can be difficult to know
what's true and what's not true
there are now
regularly claims of russian aggression
against just random civilians in
multiple instances
and here the mayor is coming out and
saying there just there are no soldiers
here anybody you see
is a civilian please don't shoot anybody
now the counter that russia has already
started is well there have been numerous
calls for a week now for any able-bodied
individual
to take up arms and so the fact that
they are civilians doesn't mean they are
unarmed or that they don't present a
threat to russian troops that's the
counter
but the mayor of croissant saying
there's no troops here
please don't shoot civilians and the
belief is that indeed a civilians have
been killed that as we told you earlier
this week a kindergarten was bombed an
orphanage was bombed etc
that's the the latest um there there is
this you know when we imagine the sort
of prototypical uh
police state kind of military rule some
of these elements are in place
um
the uh conditions set by russian forces
include a curfew from 8 p.m to 6 a.m
only going out in groups of two
and allowing only cars carrying food
medicine and supplies to enter the city
driving slowly so this is quickly
quickly taking the
uh ambiance and that that term does not
seem strong enough but the ambiance of
uh a military police state
and tomorrow on the program you know for
those saying
how long could this go on could this be
over in five days could this be months
the the answers are both yes but there
are now reports from u.s and america u.s
and british intelligence
uh and foreign foreign ministries that
this could be a 10 to 20 year conflict
now that doesn't mean it would be like
this for 20 years
but that it could be one of these
protracted uh conflicts and we'll talk
about that on tomorrow's program okay so
we talked about
some elements of this seem like russia
is pushing to take ukraine and that they
ultimately will be able to and it's a
matter of when not if that that's the
earlier story we did about russia
seizing its first major ukrainian city
corsair
we now have to talk about the numerous
stories that have been published
and videos that have been published so
we know that this is happening
of crying russian soldiers surrendering
all over ukraine and these are
legitimate believable stories business
insider some russian troops are
surrendering to ukrainian forces without
a fight as morale drops us defense
official says some russian troops have
been surrendering to ukrainian forces
with no fight
the senior official said the russian
military appears to be risk averse
the officials said among russia's
military are young draftees who have
never faced combat
you've seen it on the ground where units
are surrendering sometimes without a
fight
and they've got a lot of these soldiers
are conscripts never been in combat
before some of whom we believe weren't
even told they were going to be in
combat so we're just seeing evidence of
a bit of risk aversion russia's troops
also struggling with fuel and
sustainment issues and we've uh we
talked about that on yesterday's bonus
show this convoy of tanks which we will
talk about again on today's bonus show
reportedly moving as as slowly as three
miles per day
partially because the troops have a lack
of food and the tanks have a lack of gas
and if that's the case obviously we
would welcome that uh that being said
this official
says they will regroup they will adjust
they will change their tactics another
report captured russian soldier breaks
down in tears after being humiliated by
ukrainians a russian soldier was filmed
crying
while being humiliated by ukrainians as
the war following russia's invasion
rages on
during the video the soldier is seen
sitting some steps on some steps sobbing
with his face in his palms at the same
time a few people standing in front of
him heard swearing in ukrainian
pictures and videos showing russian
soldiers captured by ukraine
have been posted all over the place so
how could both of these things be true
how could on the one hand russia's
forces be overwhelming and taking cities
and uh by by some indications almost
inevitably ultimately going to take over
ukraine and yet there are soldiers
crying well it's because at the
individual level many of these soldiers
are completely demoralized and as the
article says some weren't told that they
would be facing combat many have never
faced combat and all of a sudden they
are there and they are just bailing at
the same time
the forces are so large russian military
forces that even if you've got hundreds
of demoralized troops saying what the
hell am i doing here i want to go home
let me call my mom
there are enough
to still continue overwhelming uh
ukrainian cities there's one video here
of uh and this there's examples of
everything this is a a surrendered
russian soldier being treated well being
given food being given drinks and
allowed to quite literally call mommy
and i'm not saying that in a pejorative
way i mean this is we're talking about
almost kids here who are just being sent
in
uh to fight a battle many of them don't
want to fight and that very few people
actually understand take a look at this
okay and i understand that the audio
alone unless uh you speak ukrainian and
or russian is not super relevant but
there is an individual here believed to
be a russian uh soldier who is drinking
uh what appears to be tea being handed
food and uh skyping skyping with his mom
and being helped to do so uh by uh
ukrainians and of course this doesn't
mean that there aren't examples of
anything you can imagine taking place
but a very interesting moment and the
question increasingly is like who really
wants to be doing this are even
are even the the russian forces who are
not surrendering
um
thrilled about this mission and um a lot
of these videos kind of tell us a lot
about
uh
not only what is going on i mean that
they say a lot about the ukrainian
people and many when russian soldiers
say hey you know what i give up i don't
want to be here i don't want to do this
they are treated well uh but just about
the dynamics on the ground and um it's
it it's it's heartbreaking quite frankly
at the same time that such horrible
things are being done
at the top level by putin and others a
lot of these soldiers and this is not
different than in the united states i
mean you could say that the predatory
nature of military recruiting in the u.s
also makes victims out of a lot of these
young people uh those who got sucked
into the war in iraq and i mean listen
it's not news to most people in our
audience there's a lot of victimhood
here real victimhood and um it is
disturbing to see
and um
when these when these things take place
like this where everybody says hey you
know what none of us want this let's all
sort of relate to each other as humans
nice moments although unfortunately they
don't change russian policy and putin
seems determined to keep going at least
for the time being
we have so much more on today's show you
can find me on twitter at dpakman and
let me know how long you think this is
going to continue we have so much more
to discuss right after this short break
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar that's why
you should check out our longtime
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon tastes
exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
david pakman show is a viewer community
supported program we really depend on
your support to do what we do and
whether you listen to the podcast or
watch a youtube clip or a live stream
here or there
i would love for you to sign up at
joinpackman.com we do offer some great
viewer perks listener perks when people
become members including a daily extra
show we do an additional show
just for our members as well as
providing commercial free audio and
video streams to you priority access
when we do viewer town halls another one
of which we should really schedule the
next one soon we should do that
for march for sure
and so many other great things you can
sign up at joinitpacman.com
if you i believe the normal membership
rates are very reasonable but if you'd
like a discount you can use the code wow
22
to save
major breaking news last night
and that is that the january 6th
committee investigating the trump riots
has now laid out in clear terms
the possible criminal charges against
donald trump now remember they can't
bring criminal charges these are members
of the house they have investigative
powers it is up to the justice
department currently guided by attorney
general merrick garland to decide are we
bringing criminal charges or not but
there was this open question for a very
long time
would the investigation
point to criminal charges against donald
trump and the answer now is yes and of
course the the million-dollar question
is
is there a prosecutor willing
to bring charges against a former
president so we'll start with a new york
times article january 6 committee
lays out potential criminal charges
against trump in a court filing the
panel said there was enough evidence to
suggest
trump might have engaged in a criminal
conspiracy as he fought to remain in
office
these are are such strange times where
outrageous things are normalized
things that would have been unthinkable
at times past
five of them happen in a week and we
just kind of don't react
this is not normal
this is a really big deal not only is
there a committee investigating riots
incited by a former president desperate
to keep his grip on power on january 6
2021
but they believe that he may have
engaged in criminal conspiracy
the house committee investigating the
riots
said there is enough evidence to
conclude
former president donald trump and some
of his allies might have conspired to
commit fraud and obstruction
by misleading americans about the
outcome of the election and attempting
to overturn the result this is a big big
deal
in a court filing in a civil case in
california the committee's lawyers for
the first time
laid out their theory of a potential
criminal case against donald trump
they said they had accumulated evidence
demonstrating that trump
the conservative lawyer john eastman and
other allies could potentially be
charged with criminal violations
including obstructing an official
proceeding of congress and conspiracy to
defraud the american people
the filing also said the men might have
broken a common law statute against
fraud
through trump's repeated lies that the
election had been stolen
had been stolen
the filing disclosed only limited new
evidence the committee asked the judge
in the civil case to review the material
behind closed doors
this is
insane
in asserting the potential for
criminality the committee largely relied
on the extensive and detailed accounts
already made public of the actions trump
and his allies took to keep him in
office after defeat
uh cbs reporting house january 6
committee says it has evidence trump and
allies engaged in quote criminal
conspiracy
the house select committee investigating
the riots said in a court filing it has
evidence trump and allies engaged in a
criminal conspiracy by trying to block
congress from certifying the election
this is the first time the committee has
laid out a potential criminal case
against donald trump
this is a significant moment in the
investigation because it includes rare
disclosure of findings excerpts from
depositions and interviews with
witnesses including mike pence's top
advisor former justice department
leaders and those close to trump
newsweek
donald trump could face criminal charges
after explosive john eastman emails
revealed remember john eastman's this
lawyer who laid out what
a theoretical framework for trying to
flip the results of the election
this is not normal
but and i know i'm getting now dozens of
emails and voicemails from viewers and
listeners every day david do you still
think trump won't go to prison
yes
yes i do
and
people who say david when you say that
it makes it less likely he will go to
prison no i'm a random guy with a
microphone
nobody no potential prosecutor cares
what i am saying it doesn't make any
difference we have a situation here
where think of the steps first
there has to be some prosecutor willing
to be the first to charge donald trump a
former president that already takes a
lot and it doesn't seem merrick garland
is going to be that guy
we've talked about southern district of
new york we've talked about manhattan
district attorney we've talked about
georgia are any of these prosecutors
willing to be the first i don't deny
that if one prosecutor filed charges
moore would fall i i believe there would
i believe that there's many prosecutors
willing to be the second prosecutor or
the third prosecutor to file charges
against trump i'm not seeing any
evidence anyone is willing to be the
first
if you did see that
in almost
99
of these types of cases
you don't get a trial
you get some kind of a plea you get
charges being dropped because things get
complicated etc if you get a trial you
don't necessarily get a guilty verdict
if you get a guilty verdict you almost
certainly don't get prison time so
think about the number of steps here so
yes if you want my opinion and that's
all it is i don't think trump does a day
in prison will we see charges at some
point maybe that's far more likely than
prison time but that is still my belief
at this point in time if you disagree
with me let me know i have an
unbelievable clip for you today
donald trump was interviewed yesterday
by fox news propagandist maria bartoromo
who has gone from being a pretty good
and respectable finance and economic
journalist
15 years ago 20 years ago to being a
trump brown noser on fox news the
ultimate trump brown noser allowing
unhinged conspiracy theories to be
spread on her programs over the last
year maria bartoromo interviewed donald
trump and it might not shock you to hear
that donald trump now says
the ukrainians are only even putting up
a fight thanks to the weapons i gave
them now you might hear that and say
wait david sir aren't those the weapons
he
delayed giving to ukraine because he
wanted dirt on biden and the answer is
yes it is exactly those weapons but
donald trump in the period of eight days
has gone from putin is savvy genius and
smart for what he's doing with ukraine
taking great property in ukraine
to actually
putin's not good this wouldn't have
happened under well he didn't say putin
is not good but he said this wouldn't
have happened under my watch to now sing
ukraine should be thanking me
that they're even putting up a fight
because they're using the weapons i gave
them listen to this delusional 180. by
the way the translation here the five
second version of this clip is
me me me me
me that's that that's the summary
now russia has gotten in deeper than
they ever thought possible so they would
frankly i think they probably would be
right now in a good position to do
something with i think they're in much
deeper than they thought to a certain
extent because of the the weapons that i
gave and that the ukrainians used
so well i mean they used so well amazing
so i think russia is something could be
done with them right now because they're
not they're not looking so good
but they are looking well they have to
you have to work out a deal they have to
stop killing these people they're
killing all these people and they have
to stop it and they have to stop it now
but they don't respect the united states
and the united states is like i don't
know they're not doing anything about it
so these are really inspirational
foreign policy assessments from donald
trump so yes trump is saying
thanks to the weapons i initially
withheld while i attempted to extort
zielenski
okay that's that's what he's that's the
translation here
thanks to those weapons i originally
withheld for the extortion i attempted
but was ultimately sort of pressured
into giving ukraine because things blew
up and alexander vinman testified and
all that stuff thanks to those weapons
ukraine now is to some degree resisting
russian aggression it is out of this
world guys completely out of this world
he withheld military aid because he
wanted zielinski to get him dirt on joe
biden open an investigation and then the
whistle was blown it wasn't a perfect
phone call he released the aid he got
impeached on and on and on and had it
not blown up in his face i mean really
understand understand the scope of that
when we go back and we remember okay
he withheld the aid but then he gave it
to them but why did he give it to them
he gave it to them because things
exploded and people found out about what
he was doing had vinman not blown the
whistle had everything that happened not
happened ukraine would not likely have
gotten those weapons or or certain
certainly not in in any kind of
reasonable uh amount of time
and so thanks to the people who blew the
whistle over what trump was doing to
extort ukraine ukraine got some of those
weapons and of course
it's also extraordinarily self-centered
because the truth is ukraine now has
received weapons and military aid from
countries all over the world and
additionally from the biden
administration so even even taken at its
face what trump is saying is absurd but
everything somehow is about him
uh uh putin was so scared of him that he
didn't do this while trump was president
the weapons that ukraine is fighting
with or thanks to trump everything is
trump it's me me me and unfortunately if
you look at interviews with trumpists
many of them have fallen for this stuff
okay one other quick story here we now
have an actual poll what did people
think
of joe biden's first official state of
the union address on tuesday remember i
gave it a b
and i thought there were some good parts
and some not so good parts
almost 80 of those who watched it
believe that uh uh joe biden was on
point and approve of his remarks that
this is surprising even to me quite
frankly nearly eight in ten of state of
the union watchers approve of joe
biden's remarks
um 78
in a new cbs yougov poll
said that they approve of biden's
remarks 22 disapproved those surveys
surveyed were also asked to check all of
the feelings that applied to them and
many said they came away with positive
feelings 67 percent said they were
optimistic 50 said they felt proud only
20 said they were pessimistic and 13
angry now uh you have to consider that
it is this is of people who watched
and um quite certainly because it's a
democratic president more of those who
watched may indeed be democrats but
there's also a cnn poll conducted by
ssrs which said 71 percent had a
positive reaction
uh although again
friendlier audiences more democrats than
republicans tend to be attracted to
these speeches a couple of different
notes here number one some of these
insta polls online a lot of right
wingers will say whoa
look at this 40 only 48 percent liked
the speech
understand that those insta polls are
worth
the gum on the
pre-chewed gum on the bottom of your
shoe
they're really worth nothing
anybody whether you saw the speech or
not can weigh in
and uh even people who might have
thought the speech was okay we'll just
lie on those those are notoriously not
accurate we really should be looking at
actual polling couple different thoughts
one there may be a little bit of a rally
around the flag going on the ukrainian
flag and we know in general approval for
presidents and approval for speeches
like these tend to be higher when there
is such a conflict in this case it's a
conflict elsewhere but it's one that
most of the world is united in terms of
who should we be supporting here uh and
that was the strongest part of biden's
speech the part about ukraine so that
may certainly be a factor the other
thing is uh it's i always like to be
reminded
that my interpretation of these things
is very different than people who don't
follow this stuff as closely and i think
it's a good reminder for all of us
because even people who listen to shows
like mine are probably not like the
average and that most people don't
listen to political stuff
or follow politics as closely as you do
who if you're watching this clip or
listening today you are not likely the
sort of average person and
although i gave it a b and thought it
had a lot of weak moments
um clearly those who watched it had a
much better impression and i think that
that's interesting for us to keep in
mind it's particularly interesting i
mean listen i gave it a b and said it
had some good parts people like ben
shapiro said this is essentially the
worst speech ever it was pathetic it was
out of touch it was filled with lies and
rambling and biden was confused he
didn't know what was going on
very few people who watched it came away
with that impression either
a lot of the focus online has been oh
biden meant to say ukrainian and he said
iranian
but the average person who watched it is
not even thinking about that and that's
an important reminder for us as well so
a well-received speech the question now
will be and monday we'll look at this
does joe biden's approval rating recover
because it's essentially at his
presidency low will will this speech
help him recover
we will see
we'll have clips from these segments on
our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
kelly weil who's a journalist at the
daily beast where she covers extremism
disinformation and the internet also
author of off the edge flat earthers
conspiracy culture and why people will
believe anything uh kelly really great
to have you on today
thanks for having me so i i want to get
a little bit to the resurgence of flat
earth specifically because i think it's
an interesting kind of window into a lot
of the the stuff that you cover but if
we zoom out a little bit um you know
when i've spoken to both extremists and
those who cover extremists often they
say that the folks most likely to fall
into these types of beliefs generally
are
folks with
on the one hand certain personality
characteristics but on the other hand
with backgrounds that are often about
not having something that they feel a
sense of belonging towards and sometimes
this relates to parenting sometimes this
relates to communities or bullying in
school or the these sort of types of
things
what's your sense covering this and
researching it about what makes folks
more likely to as you say in the title
of the book believe anything
i mean there are a few factors and one
thing that i have to flag is that we're
all susceptible to conspiratorial
thinking to some degree it's not some
weird thing that tinfoil hat people do
um it really emerges when we feel like
we don't have enough information or the
information we have isn't comforting for
us it doesn't reaffirm our priors but
you're right to bring up that sort of
sense of isolation because one of the
things that people go looking for when
they seek out
flat earth or another conspiracy theory
is a sense of belonging is a sense of
community and conspiracy theories often
work in this weirdly team-based way uh
it becomes sort of an us versus them
mentality where you're either on the the
inside of this uh small community that
says it has all the answers and the
world is out to get us or you're on the
other side and by definition evil and
scheming so i think those communities
are very alluring for people who both
want community and want answers and it
repackages them in a way that i think is
it's very appealing for certain people
the comfort thing is interesting because
one of the one of the characteristics
not not a flat earth specifically but of
some other conspiracy theories including
that
random events were actually planned what
seems to underlie it is that it's really
stressful to think or to believe that
random bad things happen that you
couldn't possibly protect yourself from
and that it's sort of a matter of chance
whether you personally are affected by
something or not it seems that some
people get comfort from believing it was
planned and at least some people knew
exactly when and how this was going to
happen
yeah and it's weird to think what's
comforting for certain people because if
you told me that you know there's a
whole bunch of evil doers in a dark room
scheming all these events it's actually
the opposite of comforting to me that's
a little distressing but for some people
that's better than the idea of pure
chaos or
they often make it very theological you
know they don't like the idea that
there's nobody looking out for them and
you know to tie this back to flat earth
one of the best
reasonings i've heard for someone
getting into flat earth theory is uh
they believe the earth is like the
universe is very small it's this little
flat earth contained under a snow globe
basically and she said that she didn't
like the idea that the universe was so
big and so random and that she was this
little point in it and when she
compressed all the uh unknown knowns
into this again really small
um
snow globe
that she realized that she was special
and she had a place in the universe and
so i think that explains a little bit of
it you you write about how there was
actually a flat earth movement in the
1830s
and um i think many people might just
say well you know we just knew a lot
less then but but actually 1830 was not
the start of when we started to realize
that the the spherical earth is actually
what it is can you talk a little bit
about kind of what led that movement and
what the beliefs were based on
totally so you're right i mean we've
known for more than 2000 years now that
earth is round and it's because it's
actually pretty easy to prove old-timey
mathematicians in greece and egypt were
doing this for ages
what happened in the 1830s 1840s
was it was a time of upheaval it was a
time of technological and scientific
uh revolution and that is a moment when
people go looking for alternative
answers and
as new ideas of science and evolution
we're forcing religion to take the
backseat in a lot of people's minds
people started looking for reasons to
discount science and flat earth emerged
from this really uh wacky character he
was a failed commune leader he sold
fake medical cures for a while he had
this theory that because earth looks
flat it must be flat and
not only that but it's um
that scientists are actively colluding
to hide the reality from you so for
people who wanted to opt out of new
fields of science this was the golden
ticket
right and when we think about the
resurgence of flat earth like over the
last six to ten years
it's interesting that we have so many
more technological means available to us
now and so many different ways to to
easily prove that the earth is not flat
and yet it it has still resurged but on
a sort of different basis right
absolutely you know um
it's funny for about 200 years now
we've been um watching flat earthers
come up with new reasons to discard new
scientific evidence
in the um during the space phrase flat
earthers had to contend with okay why
are there pictures of earth from outside
earth if we're all underneath this snow
globe um and increasingly i'm seeing
people
not um
really try to contend with the evidence
at all but say that any new conflicting
evidence is actually proof of a scheme
against them it's uh it's fabricated
it's there to deceive them
so
one thing is that this theory and many
other conspiracy theories are not really
about the provability or the
believability they're about people's
willingness to
believe against all odds and when you
get that kind of motivated reasoning it
becomes really easy to just chuck out
evidence that you don't like you know in
the past when when i've interviewed
experts on conspiracism and
conspiratorial thinking often we kind of
start from the point of flat earth being
one of the most benign
non-empirically based sort of
conspiratorial beliefs and that it might
exist in a sort of isolated benign space
but many of these folks who who study
this say well
rarely do people just have one of these
beliefs and so there's really more than
random overlap between
like flat earth beliefs
illuminati one world government
anti-semitic beliefs you know that all
these different things are linked more
than you would expect by random chance
and so while flat earth specifically
might sort of be benign
it's often
the same types of folks that go to the
flat earth conferences that are that are
doing some of the other stuff do you do
you agree with that assessment disagree
with it partially agree
i absolutely agree and i think it's
getting worse too um i started following
flat earth around 2017 and even at that
time i thought it was a little bit more
siloed i didn't see so much interchange
with other conspiracy theories whereas
now i see a lot more active networking
what would have been uh purely flat
earth facebook page uh 2017 is now
sharing a lot of kobe disciple or uh
thinly veiled q anon and you know it
does make sense in a way because if you
believe in something so literally world
encompassing as flat earth
you're not going to believe that every
other established reality holds true you
know
flat earth lets you just knock down all
the facts and build your own and so it's
very easy for people to draw on
pre-existing conspiracy theories and
you're right to note that a lot are
anti-semitic or hateful in nature one of
the interesting things about flat earth
is there's there's this kind of common
belief which i think is borne out by the
studies which is
you can't just give facts to folks who
believe certain things and and sometimes
the more facts you give them the more
they actually resist changing their
perspective and the interesting thing in
that context about flat earth is
that
the they have rebuttals to just about
every purported rebuttals i think i
should say to just about every empirical
claim that you can present to them with
data and with facts and and with
observation and so it's sort of like the
perfect um
experiment as to what does get folks to
revise their beliefs when it comes to
people who were flat earthers
but were disabused of those beliefs what
has worked effectively
what has worked with the ex-flat
earthers that i've spoken to is not
exactly debate because i think when
people debate they dig into their own um
beliefs they
double down they don't want to be proven
wrong
what i've found has helped in the
limited cases of
d conversions because i think people
need to be willing to deconvert
is they've had compassionate discussions
with round arthurs people who aren't
here to belittle them or prove them
wrong or have one of these awful uh
youtube livestream debates but say okay
why
did you come to this belief and
you know what emotionally is motivating
you to do this and
um
what can we do that's observable to you
you know can we go watch the sunset over
the horizon will that help
um and that kind of compassionate
exchange one that you know takes into
account the humanity of the person that
you're trying to talk to and the
emotional needs that drive them to
conspiracy theories often i think is a
lot more fruitful than this um
this belittling or
i keep using the term team based but
it's
conspiracy theories are very team based
and if you turn it into an us versus
them debate
it follows that's not going to convert
somebody
what are the um motives that flat
earthers believe
explain why the powers that be so to
speak would want folks believing that
the earth is actually spherical when
it's flat
that's a really tough one and it's one
that i ask a lot of flat earthers and i
get a range of answers and quite a lot
of people say i don't really know
um i mean the upsetting answers a lot of
people will say something pretty
anti-semitic right or
why would the jews benefit from the
earth really being flat but people
thinking it's spherical like i don't
even know right right i mean you know it
just
none of these theories because they're
you know it goes back it's building on
centuries of
uh conspiratorial frameworks none of
them actually hold up there's no reason
a religious group would want to
disguise the earth's shape but you know
they'll make those callbacks or they'll
use something a bit more veiled the
illuminati the new world order they'll
say that um maybe
we uh that the powers that be want to
downplay the role of religion in the
world or they want to keep people
confused or the best answer i ever got
was this guy so flat earthers generally
don't believe in outer space
and this guy is like well what i think
is going on is they want us to believe
in space so they want us to believe in
aliens so that when jesus comes down
again we'll think he's an alien and
we'll kill him so
that's that's pretty tough to talk
someone out of i mean that's the crazy
thing about it oh that was really rough
because i mean he clearly thought about
this for much longer than i was ever
going to yeah um
but the long and short of it is people
are really willing to believe this
theory and sometimes the specifics or
even the motivation comes secondary
can you talk a little bit about um the
social media platform algorithms like on
facebook and youtube and specifically
like with flat i think many in my
audience generally understand uh
controversy does better algorithmically
so then in general platforms will share
articles that are negative divisive etc
with no regard for whether they are
accurate or not but what what are we
seeing about these algorithms
specifically with flat earth
flat earth has performed really really
well historically in social media
algorithms especially on youtube there's
a period from about 2014 to 2019 when
flat earth videos got this massive
artificial boost and the reason is i
mean youtube is a company they want to
make money and they make money from you
staying on the site and watching videos
yeah um and so because uh flat earth was
something that i am guilty of this too
everybody clicks on it two in the
morning
um those videos perform very well
algorithmically and people would get
recommended to them even if they weren't
seeking them out so
youtube did change its algorithm after
tons of criticism by 2019 but the fact
still stands for five years this was a
really just like open fire hose of flat
earth info into unsuspecting people's
speeds
uh last thing i wanted to talk about can
you talk a little bit about in the in
the culture in the landscape right now
of conspiracy theories and and sort of
extremist beliefs what are maybe some
less known things that are maybe coming
up i mean i think q anon my audience
knows about flat earth election was
stolen vaccines are killing millions but
nobody you know the some of the obvious
ones i think my audience is aware of but
is there anything kind of like up and
coming that you're tracking
oh man um
the question is always like whether to
talk about it if it's up and coming
right um you know i think
to put it a different way i mean there
are always french theories on the up
what i think is different now is the um
their embrace in uh mainstream
republican politics so whereas cuna was
something that was you know on its face
completely absurd and deranged um now
we're seeing this much more
uh wholesale embrace of things like
election conspiracy theories by the
republican party and you know as much as
i
will criticize things for like social
media for their role in promoting
conspiracy theories this i think is
uncharted or
not recently chartered territory you
mean the degree to which the republican
party has participated
exactly the um their role in promoting
it and the role in normalizing it and i
think that is pretty dangerous and
as much as you know we can
rail on the youtubes and the facebooks
for promoting this info
this is an integral part of american
politics and it is just diving all the
way in on conspiracy theories do you
have an opinion as to for how long will
they continue with the evidence is just
about to come out i mean because it's
we're at 15 months now and rudy giuliani
and trump and i mean they continue to
say we're we're about to get the stuff
from georgia we're about to get the
stuff from er will does this have a long
life ahead of it you think
i think it does but not because they're
gonna keep claiming the evidence is
coming out
it's like flat earth where the evidence
doesn't really matter it's an emotional
appeal right
so after they see this narrative for so
long it doesn't really matter that they
keep getting disproven because people
believe it there's enough of this
saturation of the story that people want
to believe and
by that point they've already you know
taken down uh voting sites in
predominantly black neighborhoods that
already have passed legislation that
makes it difficult to send in absentee
ballots and that i think is like the
real tangible risk of this conspiracy
theorizing is it enables things that are
very real yeah at this point it's almost
like they're signaling their membership
in a team by repeating that rather than
we literally are waiting around for the
evidence
totally yeah if only they were waiting
around because i mean they'll be doing
that until they die for a very long time
yeah
kelly weil is a journalist at the daily
beast the book is off the edge flat
earthers conspiracy culture and why
people will believe anything kelly
really appreciate your time
thanks for having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right let's do a
little bit of follow-up about what is
the most disgusting moment during any
state of the union address that i can
remember and at this point this is an
important story because
it wasn't just that lauren bobert
heckled joe biden during the state of
the union
and it wasn't just that lauren beaubert
radical republican congresswoman heckled
joe biden when biden was talking about
his son who died and served in the
military during the state of the union
but it's about the fact that so many
republicans are refusing to condemn it
and it's about the fact that many in
right-wing media are celebrating what
lauren bobert did and it's absolutely
and completely disgusting so let's start
with our first example this is
republican congressman james comer
who was given the opportunity to condemn
uh what lauren bobert did remember
marjorie taylor green also yelling out
and turning her back to joe biden and he
doesn't do it he doesn't do it and it
wouldn't be that difficult to do it you
could do it in a way where you st you
still say
i mean listen at this point
you could say i completely condemn what
they did but i also am worried about xyz
thing that biden did right like it's
pretty straightforward to put together a
statement like that
that's not what he does look at look at
this disgusting response congressman
before we let you go i do want to ask
you about what we all saw and heard
frankly last night from the chamber two
of your colleagues lauren bobert marjon
taylor green were shouting at the
president throughout his speech one
moment that i think a lot of people
heard she shouted out 13 of them when
the president was talking about soldiers
in a flag draped coffins do you think
that type of behavior is appropriate
well certainly
whether you agree or disagree with the
president i believe during the state of
the union
we should all show respect to the
president but honestly but honestly but
honestly this is the same and we'll get
through this is like those tweets
putin shouldn't invade ukraine
but and then something horrible follows
it share their frustration when you look
at the crises that we're facing in this
country
but should they be should they be
vocalizing that in the middle of his
state of the union address does that not
undercut your party and its messaging on
those critical issues
well it's certainly not my style
i've heard that type of behavior from
democrats to when we had republican
presidents no actually no that's not
true that's not true there have the two
main heckling incidents are joe wilson
heckling barack obama and bobert and
green heckling joe bide those are the
incidents
i just think that uh the best
democrats yelled at the republican
president of the chamber when did that
happen
yeah well when donald trump was was
president so the the thing that
you know
that's not true i think congress should
do is just listen and then we have an
opportunity like i'm doing now to speak
to the america and speak to the press
about our disagreements and move on
all right congressman james so what do
you guys think i mean it's it's not like
bobert and greene are so prominent in
the party leadership that these are
people that you can't be
um
adversarial with or whatever the case
may be like is this is this guy a coward
is he merely a bad person like what do
you guys think is the explanation
because it's not exactly a profile in
courage
and um it's even
less likely to be condemned
when right-wing media is sort of
cheerleading the entire thing and that's
uh what i want to talk about next
so after heckling joe biden during
tuesday night's state of the union
address yelling out when joe biden was
literally talking about his son that
died lauren bobert yelling out
in the aftermath of that
she sort of like got a hero's welcome in
a lot of different places and she was
interviewed by turning point usa's
charlie kirk now if you don't know
charlie kirk and you don't know turning
point i envy you but in all seriousness
it's a very well-funded organization
that is pulling in young people to
radical right ideology and they do it
very very effectively charlie kirk
interviewed lauren bober and she
defended her actions saying listen i was
very caught up in the emotion because i
am so worried about the troops that died
under joe biden take a look and so i
think you wore a drill baby drill shirt
as well um yesterday and a lot of the
state of the union is theater so now i
gotta ask you congresswoman because
we've been receiving a lot of emails and
some of our listeners are divided um i
think you could probably see part of why
they're divided because we really went
after nancy pelosi when she tore the
speech we said have some respect for the
president what do you have to say for
people that say hey look i'm with you
congresswoman but maybe you shouldn't
interrupt the president at the state of
the union what's your thought on that
uh first of all i you know i was really
caught up in the emotions of it uh right
so first so right off the bat she
basically is is saying
it's like a moral get out of jail free
card it was it was a moment of passion
it's sort of like you killed someone
well it was a crime of passion i wasn't
thinking she was so caught up in the
emotion that that's supposed to be like
a blanket exculpation for what she did
mentioning uh afghanistan but didn't
bother to mention the 13 soldiers uh he
went on to something totally different
and uh that's totally different yeah his
dead son totally different really just
overwhelmed me and i couldn't help but
speak out and look i would love to have
a conversation in a better setting with
him right and and the way to get such a
conversation is by heckling him when he
talks about his son who died and that's
you know uh kyle rittenhouse the other
day
he said on some show we're gonna we
might sue joe biden he might get a
letter
it's like oh where lee why well he's
like yeah well i asked him to meet with
me five times and he didn't and it's the
same type of uh of idea here she would
like to meet with joe biden but joe
biden hasn't met with her so she heckled
them while he was talking about dead
soldiers and his son who died and and
now he's going to meet with you i i
would love to be able to talk to him and
maybe i'll get the chance to do that
when republicans are in the majority in
2023 and we can actually put forward my
articles of impeachment for joe biden
and have a real conversation yeah uh
you're not gonna you're also not gonna
have a conversation with joe biden if
you put forward your silly articles of
impeachment which she and marjorie
taylor green have been talking about now
for months and as far as the drill baby
drill uh goes joe biden he waged a war
on american energy and left us in a very
dangerous place we rely on russian
energy importing nearly 600 000 barrels
of energy per day now i want to talk
about this a little bit
a very popular talking point has become
we were energy independent under joe
biden and now we are not the data is
widely available we cited it in our
story about energy independence a couple
weeks ago
for the last several years the u.s
production of oil
has matched u.s consumption of oil now
you have to understand that under biden
and under trump even though that's the
case there is still trading going on
and
we send some oil abroad and also bring
some oil in but in terms of the numbers
for several years now
we've produced as much oil as we've
consumed so the idea that joe biden has
done any drastic thing where now we are
not at that same equivalent level of
production and uh uh use is just a lie
and she keeps repeating it
no one challenges it it's not true when
we should be energy independent and
certainly
energy dominant we should be able to
export energy to our allies which is
literally exporting freedom and uh so i
i wore drill baby drill on my shaw to
remind the democrats of exactly what we
should be doing yeah no one cares about
that and how we should stop funding
russia's war yeah and that's that's a
lot of the state of the union is kind of
like making
alternative points and i think people
understand that and i'll be honest like
if i was in the audience i don't know if
i would have been able to contain myself
so i think that's a that's a fair answer
if i had to listen to joe biden go on
and yep charlie kirk would have done the
same thing so there's this soft defense
of the completely indefensible and
they're they're not going to stop
they're going to continue doing it and
we're it
unless these folks are just removed or
forced to behave differently they will
continue escalating and it's not going
to change and that shouldn't surprise
anybody hey why do people call me
to have me defend communism
i'm not a communist why would you call
me to have me defend that here's a
voicemail our voicemail number is 2192
david p
and
i just don't get why does anyone care to
have me defend communism i'm not a
communist this is very this guy calls in
all the time asking me to defend things
that just have nothing to do with me
hey david it's fun again yeah
a very concise question please like
these
if communism
is so great
according to people that support
communism well talk to them i'm not one
of those people
then why do they prohibit their people
from living
from leaving the country
that communism rings in right if it's
true that it's very good they wouldn't
need to restrict people from leaving
they would just
leave it open
and naturally the people would just stay
there because it's a great system sure
so if it's a great system
uh
why are they prohibited from leaving
you know what i screwed up because i
wasn't very concise but you get where
i'm going right i like to hear your
thoughts yeah
ask a communist juan
don't ask me i i don't defend communism
on this show this is a great opportunity
for me to mention uh later this month
i am going to be in florida
and i am going to appear on the
patrickbetdavidpodcast he's got a huge
youtube channel three four million
subscribers he's got a podcast it's a
long form podcast
patrickbetdavid is not on the left and
he asked for a progressive to come on
and explain and defend progressivism and
i said i'll do it and he said let's do
it we're going to have you on now one of
the things i'm not going to do on that
show is defend stuff that i don't
believe in so um
you know the one of the difficult things
about these these types of interviews is
it's very plausible that i'll go down
there and he'll go
uh
how can you defend like just as just an
example how can you defend the women's
march not allowing jewish women on their
leadership because jewish women aren't
intersectional enough i'd go no no i
don't you gotta ask someone who who
supports that i don't i don't support
that this is like one silly example but
the point is
i'm not going to defend positions that
are not mine i will tell him you got to
ask someone who believes that and i will
say if it's something that's some kind
of fringe thing
um
not very many people on the left
actually believe that and it's sort of
like saying well
do we do we need mitt romney
or would we have asked the late john
mccain
to defend some uh you know richard
spencer or some white nationalist or
something no it doesn't make any sense
so
have me defend things i believe in i'm
not a communist i'm not here to do
apologia for communism all right my
friend thank you very much on the bonus
show today
the russian convoy appears stalled
because the tanks don't have much gas
and a lot of crazy things are happening
we're going to talk about that on the
bonus show today the governor of iowa
has signed a flat tax into law
many states actually have a flat tax so
it's not as unusual as you might think
but we'll talk about flat taxes more
generally and yes oil prices are surging
as uh there are reports which we will
talk about tomorrow that the russia
ukraine war could last could last 10 to
20 years but hopefully it won't and if
it did it wouldn't be like the current
situation but we'll talk about all of
that on today's bonus show producer pat
will join me
don't miss the bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com
and get instant access
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman